we do want to acknowledge and thank
Tyler Perry who we spoke with who will
be taking care of the funeral for the
family Tyler Perry is giving back in a
big way
following Rashard Brooks death it's
support like that and it's people who
are actually in this community that love
the community that want healing and
families like this to never have to go
through something like this just step
forward during a press conference on
Monday Attorney L Chris Stewart revealed
that the Hollywood mogul is covering the
cost of Rey shards funeral we want to
thank him for such a generous move
Rashard a 27 year old black man was
fatally shot by police at a Wendy's
drive-thru in Atlanta Georgia after
officials said he resisted arrest and
stolen officers taser an autopsy found
that Rashard suffered two gunshot wounds
to his back and died from organ injuries
and blood loss the manner of death was
listed as homicide
less than a day after his death Atlanta
Police Chief Erika shields stepped down
from her role Garret Rolf the officer
who shot Rashard was fired another
officer at the scene devin brosnan was
placed on administrative duty
Rashard skilling was caught by
surveillance cameras police body cameras
dashboard cameras and bystanders I'm
already in enough pain right now so to
see anything of my husband being shot
down or
I can see on Monday his wife Tamika
Miller spoke with the Today Show and
said she can't bring herself to watch I
can't stomach dead right now I think he
healed the heart the pain nothing's
gonna bring him back
and again it keeps going on and going on
I'm not the only one going through it
Tamika said that she's dreading her
husband's funeral because it means
explaining death to their four children
particularly to their daughter who just
turned eight and I had to explain to her
what death is how we got a hit go they
were gonna be great for your father ray
shards death has sparked another wave of
intense protests against police
brutality and racial injustice and some
of Hollywood's biggest stars are
speaking out Kim Kardashian urged her
Twitter followers to sign a petition
seeking justice for Rashard while Justin
Timberlake shared a pic of Rashard
holding one of his daughters on
Instagram writing as a dad
this photo hurts Rashard Brooks was a
father of three girls one two and eight
years old he should not be dead
meanwhile Billy Eilish took to Instagram
to let her fans know she is so [ __ ]
angry adding the justice for Rashard
Brooks the justice for Ray chard why
isn't everyone talking about this